ça reste un métier quand même où la
pédagogie joue un rôle énorme et où
l'autorité évidemment s'est délité comme
vous le disiez et les difficiles à
remettre parce que derrière il n'y a pas
du tout de politique alors si on a quand
même jean michel blanquer requis à
sortir le carré régaliens alors c'est
magnifique je sais pas si vous avez vu
ce petit dispositif
c'est un petit carré avec un drapeau
français qu'il a fait à graffer dans
tous les collèges et lycées de france
qui expliquent le respect a donc il faut
pour que ça marche l'école de la
république le respect des valeurs de la
république la prévention des violences
la lutte contre le harcèlement et la
prévention de la radicalisation voilà ce
que doivent faire les professeurs alors
ça va drôlement et des ans ces petites
flèches qui tire de tous les côtés ont
l'impression qu'ils sont écartelés pour
pour ne rien dire autrement et c'est le
drapeau français qu'on écarte elle
finalement à savoir que ce que vous
voulez faire de ça voilà les outils
pédagogiques qu'on donne aux professeurs
aujourd'hui sous le ministère de jean
michel blanquer r c'est assez inquiétant
[Musique]